souvent une page politique à présent ils
sont onze à s'engager dans la primaire à
droite en vue de la présidentielle de
2017 mais un seul est pour le moment
qualifié le député yves binois jean
frédéric poisson 53 ans
si les autres devront trouver des
parrainages d'élus à travers toute la
france
ce dernier en tant que président du
parti chrétien-démocrate n'aura pas à
répondre à cette obligation en tant que
formation autonome elle peut désigner
son candidat et n'a besoin que d'une
confirmation du bureau politique et des
républicains c'est désormais chose faite
depuis hier soir et malgré ce privilège
d'entrer dans les poissons n'est pas
tendre avec ses adversaires on les
écoute il était ce matin au micro de
fanny bourdillon je pense que l'immense
majorité des candidats qui se sont
présentés sinon tous étaient membres du
gouvernement en mai 2012 lorsque nous
avons perdu les échéances
présidentielles et législatives
d'une manière ou d'une autre leur
responsabilité est engagée dont ce qui a
été notre défaite au printemps il ya
quatre ans et deuxièmement le message
que je porte jusqu'ici n'a pas
d'équivalent je suis un candidat qui
affirme ne pas enfin je ne veux pas
donner plus de droits qu'il me faut à
logique de marché je ne suis pas libéral
je ne suis pas atlantiste je ne suis pas
fédéraliste
sur le plan européen alors que tous mes
autres concurrents le sont